If you want to hear the secrets behind the
demon that possessed the Annabelle doll then
stick around to the end of this video.
I don't know why I'm doing this.
I hope you weren’t tired of possessed doll
movies after all those Child’s Play episodes
I just released, because playtime is not over
quite yet.
Today on Things You Missed, I’ll be covering
Annabelle.
Annabelle is a series spun-off of James Wan’s
The Conjuring, and this story contains plenty
of covert references, easter eggs and links
to real world mythology.
We’ll start at the chronological beginning
-- where the opening title is displayed over
this demonic looking statue.
This guy looks exactly like Malthus, the actual
demon that Mia first discovers in the storage
area -- so I think that this guy, like his
counterpart Valak from The Nun, has been around
for a long long time, and someone many years
ago encountered this demon and made the statue
to depict him.
The father gives his sermon where he tells
of the commandment,
“That you love one another as I have loved
you.
Greater love hath no one than this: that he
lay down his life for his friends.”
This is a foreshadowing of the end of the
movie where, Evelyn does just that -- gives
up her life to try to save John and Mia’s
baby.
After the church service, Mia goes to find
her neighbor, Sharon Higgins.
Roll it.
“Pete send you after me?
I swear he thinks one day I’ll just run
off too...”
Although we don’t know it yet, she’s talking
about their daughter, Annabelle Higgins, who
ran away as a teenager.
"A man and his wife were brutally stabbed to
death my their estranged daughter, Annabelle
Higgins, and her unidentified boyfriend."
John later mentions that she had run off to
join up with the hippies, but she actually
left to join up with a cult known as the Disciples
of Ram.
If you listen to the TV playing in the background
at the house, it reveals more about this cult:
They call themselves the family, but police
officials have labeled them as a dangerous
cult.
Residing on the grounds of Spahn Ranch, the
family is estimated to have close to 30 members
who are responsible for the Tate and LaBianca
murders, their leader is Charles Manson and
they are involved in Satanic activities.
There are a couple of instances in Annabelle
where the TV predicts what’s going to happen
next, and this is one of them.
The runaway Annabelle Higgins brings another
cult member along as they kill her parents,
then go next door to attack the pregnant Mia.
One more important detail: Annabelle dies
with the doll in her arms, giving off the
illusion that she transferred the demon into
Annabelle.
In the prequel Annabelle: Creation, we find
out about how Annabelle Higgins was possessed
by the demon, but that doesn’t explain how
John ended up with the doll.
He gives it to his wife as a gift, but doesn’t
really explain where he found it.
"Where did you find her?
I mean... you know how long I've been looking?"
"I know."
"I'd completely lost hope."
"I have my ways."
I don’t think this is a coincidence.
We also don’t find out how the doll ended
up going from Evelyn’s dying arms to this
collectors shop at the end of the movie, or
how it got from the trash can to John’s
new apartment -- so my theory is that the
demon is looking for families he thinks are
vulnerable.
Mia and John were good candidates, because
she was already a doll collector and they
lived next door to the Higginses so they could
see the murders take place, and thus be more
likely to believe that something had possessed
the doll.
Because remember, it’s explained at the
beginning of the Conjuring that the demon
doesn’t really possess the doll, but just
moves it around to try to trick people into
offering up their souls.
Annabelle is found dead holding the doll in
the nursery with this symbol on the wall.
If you rotate it, it looks like the letter
A. This symbol re-appears throughout the movie:
like the scar on Mia’s arm after being attacked
by Malthus, and the one of the images in the
book that Mia reads to investigate the occult
and the Disciples of Ram.
The letter A also appears near the end of
the movie after the nursery has been attacked.
There’s a big A block that was never there
before, and the baby’s name starts with
the letter L, not A.
One more thing note on the attack, the cult
member accompanying Annabelle has a Ram belt
buckle, an early clue that the cult is, in
fact, performing some kind of ritual involving
Malthus, as the detective puts it later on,
“Their act wasn’t devotional, they were
they were actually trying to ‘Conjure’ something
up.”
“Like what?”
“The devil, demons, the tooth fairy, I don't
know specifically.”
I can’t wait for the Conjuring spin-off
on the tooth fairy.
I’m turning up on day 1 for that one.
Let’s look at some of the repeated symbols
throughout the house.
We see this a lot in the movies we cover here
on Things You Missed, but there are a tons
of flower images decorating the house.
We keep seeing them over and over and over
and over again.
There are also a lot of butterfly images,
and when you put these together, you have
a pollination and fertility metaphor, which
goes along with the newborn baby being the
central focus of this film.
The other symbol I saw a ton of in the house
was owls, these are hidden everywhere.
They show up so much that I have no doubt
they are meant to be noticed, but how you
interpret them may vary.
I see them as mysterious nocturnal creatures,
much like the demons of the Conjuring universe.
Owls are also often seen as symbols of wisdom,
and Father Perez later tells them that the
more they know about their enemies, the less
they will fear them.
“Isn't it true that the more we know about
something the less fear we have from it.
We need to face our fears to better understand
them."
The great thing about the father is that he
always talks like that.
Like even in a regular conversation.
Imagine if I did that in my videos.
Here lies, the things you missed, that have
been bestowed upon us by the director John
Leonetti, who also made Mortal Kombat Annihilation.
I’m done.
I’m ****ing done.
After the demon starts a fire that burns up
the house, Mia has the baby and they move
into the Palmeri Apartments.
The name Palmeri refers to the cleric who
carries a palm branch in religious ceremonies,
another tie into the religious themes of the
movie.
The doll somehow follows them there, and as I
mentioned earlier, some satanic symbols start
to show up.
I think these light ballasts resemble the
number 6, and there seem to be 3 of them:
666.
They also live on the sixth floor, and when
Mia encounters Malthus downstairs, she gets
into the elevator and mashes the 6 button
three times.
This scene also gives us our best look at
Malthus.
We usually only see him manipulating the Annabelle
doll and occasionally using the forms of Annabelle
Higgins.
As I did for Valak in my video on The Nun,
I’ll bring up the lights so we can get a
better look at the true form.
This demon seems to have claw like hands and
the ability to climb on walls or ceilings.
You also may have also missed the demon hiding
behind the curtain when Mia turns off the
record player.
If you pause when Mia is flipping through
The Devil’s Welcome, the book which is basically
the movie equivalent of The Lesser Key of
Solomon, you can find more information
about Malthus and the Disciples of Ram.
To put it into easy to understand terms, it
basically says that there are rules, and you
have to agree to give up your soul to this
demon before he can possess you.
If you do, it’s everlasting, so there’s
no going back on it, no crossed fingers clause,
nothing to get you out of this deal.
The making of this deal is something that
the church fears.
The Disciples can summon the demon by shedding
one’s blood, which is what we saw at the
beginning of the movie, but this is only to
be done as a sacrifice to Malthus, and not
for food, unless this is meat given to them
by the demon specifically for food.
And he basically wants to take over every
living creature on earth eventually.
The picture depicts the detail that we eventually
learn from Father Perez, that a baby doesn’t
really know how to agree to give up it’s
soul, so it could be potentially an easier
target -- though that doesn’t seem to be
the case for Lia.
Flipping through some of the other pages of
The Devil’s Welcome, we can see some other
connections and other demons.
The image of the snake eating its tail is
something that’s seen many times in connection
with Valak, the marquis of snakes, who appears
in The Conjuring 2 and The Nun, alongside
that same image of the snake.
There’s also an illustration of Beleth,
the Mighty King of Hell, and mention of Belial,
the demon without a master.
On the next page there’s a Abaddon, the
angel of the abyss.
Unfortunately, the page on the tooth fairy
is missing, but I think these are demons that
it does show are all good candidates to be
the antagonist of future Conjuring universe
movies.
One of the other books on the shelf in Evelyn’s
store is called Ghosts, Spirits and Apparitions,
by Anthony Astrino.
Anthony Astrino is the name of a writer for
a series called The Mentalist, which is about
a famous psychic, much like Lorraine Warren
is in the this universe.
This isn’t a real book by the way, they
just borrowed his name for it.
The name of Father Perez’s apartment complex
is The Barclay, a reference to Andy Barclay,
the main character of the Child’s Play franchise,
which is the other major killer doll movie
series that exists, so nice to see them pay
a little homage.
When they tell the Father of the occurrences
that have been going on, he says he doesn’t
know how to stop the demon, but someone at
the church might.
Roll it.
“At the very least, I’ve heard of a married
couple that the church has worked with in
the past that deal with this type of thing.
They’re back east, but a call can always
be placed.”
He’s referencing the Warrens, the main characters
of the mainline Conjuring films who live in
Connecticut.
Now, remember how I said the TV can be sign
of things to come?
The General Hospital clip that plays while
Mia is asleep on the couch leads up to the
sequence where Father Perez tries taking the
doll to the church with the belief that he
can weaken it that way, then get air yeeted
straight into the hospital, where John is
working.
So that leaves Mia and Evelyn to fight off
the demon on her own.
Mia is about to give the demon her soul in
exchange for her baby, but Evelyn sacrifices
herself instead, ‘that he lay down his life
for his friends’ or in this case, for her
friends.
However, as we know, all this does is transfers
the demon to someone else.
Also, do they not get blamed for killing Evelyn?
I mean... maybe they should have thought that
one through a bit more.
But we don’t see the scene where I’m assuming
Mia and John are taken away in handcuffs,
instead we skip forward a little under a year
to this woman entering a collectors’ shop.
In the background, you can spot an actual
Raggedy Ann doll.
This is the supposedly haunted doll in the
real life that the movie is based on, but
because of licensing issues and in order to
make it look more creepy, they made Annabelle
a porcelain doll for the movies.
This woman buys the doll for her daughter
who is a nurse.
"I'm just trying to find something for my
daughter.
Thanks.
She's a nurse.
Always helping people."
The women who explain their paranormal experiences
with Annabelle in the opening scene of both
this movie and The Conjuring are the nurses.
"I mean, we're nurses, we help people."
So one of them must be this woman’s daughter.
I also find it interesting that we never see
the cashier who sells Annabelle to the old
woman on screen.
Maybe the demon took over this cashier in
order pass on Annabelle to a new family, just
as John mysteriously found the doll his wife
was looking for.
Let me know your thoughts on that in the comments.
And make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, because next week
I’ll be covering the prequel, Annabelle:
Creation.
Remember to ring that deathbell for notifications
and I’ll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.